All right, let’s take a look at one more path type algorithm
that is simple variation of what we’re just looking at.
I’d like you to do is modify the path finding algorithm that we’ve been playing with
to find the average of the shortest path distance to each reachable node.
So, that will give for some node V₁ that we get to the program,
it will give us a measure of the centrality of V₁.
Okay, here’s the code that we left off with.
Let’s make some modifications to this to compute the centrality measure.
Program path (G, V₁, V₂) was returning to distance between V₁ and V₂ in the graph
in the graph or false if the two nodes are disconnected.
We don’t really need that anymore.
What we really need is the centrality concept and that really is done with respect
to a single starting node V and we’re going to do basically the same search as before.
We’re just not going to terminate what we had in ending node because there isn’t any node.
So, we start off distance from the start at V as being zero.
Once again, we go to our open list, pull the first element off at the
current node that we were working on, pop it off the list.
We look at the neighbors of that node.
If this neighbor is a new neighbor,
then we make a note of it’s distance which is distance from the start to the node we just where
plus one to get the distance to the neighbor then we put it on the open list and take out this line
where stopped the search and when we’re going to return at the end of all these.
Well, once this is loop is finish, once the open list is exhausted,
we visited all the nodes that were reachable and put their distances from the start state
into this data structure distance from the start.
So now, what we really need to do is average all these values of distance from the start.
There’s a lot of different ways that you can do this
but Python give you at least one way that’s very sync, so I’m going to use that.
You can also do this by setting a pair from loop but what it is in this case is
I take the other values in the distance from start date of structure.
If the return has a big long list, sum up all the elements at list, add zero to it,
0.0 to make sure that it’s a floating-point number,
and then divide by the number of nodes for which we got a distance.
So, these are all the reachable nodes.
So, ultimately, this is going to return the average of the distances of all the reachable nodes,
which is what we are looking for.
One little here and we should be good to go.